well twitter sure has shown us that they
have a quick trigger finger when it
comes to censoring conservatives
but when progressives began hurling a
racial slur at gop senator tim scott
the tech giant decided to let it trend
for like 11 hours
before taking action the onslaught of
hate came after tim scott argued in a
rebuttal to biden
that america is not a racist country
what what a concept
which might explain why twitter let the
bigoted rhetoric slide for so long
here now is vernon jones a former
democrat who is now running for governor
of georgia and
good luck to georgia it sounds fabulous
but you are running sir as a republican
welcome aboard and thank you for joining
me tonight
thank you so much i'm honored to be here
i'm here with friends with the evans
family here in cartersville georgia
which is a great community and
you know we have all these folks in
georgia that uh looking forward to
this upcoming election i want to say
that and you know george is it's a red
state's not a blue state and brian kemp
cave in to the left just like a lot of
the others
have caved into left and you mentioned
something earlier about what's happening
senator tim scott he's a great american
and when he said that he didn't think
there was racism here i guess he heard a
little bit
why because there is racism if it were
not then the democrats would not be
calling him
a [ __ ] and all those other names so the
real racism and the bigotry
is in a democratic party that's led by
none other than who
joe crow biden and let's be clear about
one thing
liberals are horrified by myself and tim
and other african-americans who are
independent who don't want to be on that
plantation and this is a tactic
to destroy them and to run them back on
the plantation
but listen that dog won't hunt we're
here we're here to stay
we want to save america we're going to
put america first we support the legacy
of donald trump
and we're going to continue to take this
fight to the left i'm not afraid of
states that abrams like
governor brian o'camp is they can't play
that race card on me
they are the racist and you know that
tammy and you're going to take the fight
directly to them
well that's very exciting obviously it
takes uh you know a lot of us we talk
about
how to make a difference and then there
are those of you who stand up and put
yourself in front
but it is especially as minorities a lot
of people don't know i'm a gay woman
and there's a dynamic where whether
you're a black or gay or a woman
there is this presumption that you are
owned by a certain section of politics
and that if you do not conform you will
be punished it is obscene it is what we
fought a civil war
over to escape to get out of and this is
what's
it's very powerful for americans to see
and everyone to see especially as
minorities
who are affected first by economic
change
who benefit from it most when it's good
as under president trump
and then who are hurt by it the most uh
when it comes by
driven by a jimmy carter or a joe biden
this
is the ownership of what has to happen
and have voices
speak about the difference but when it
comes to someone like tim scott
they clearly seem to be frightened by
him they are frightened by you
because the single voice that steps up
can make the huge difference
and we can point out what this means do
you think
that when it comes to certainly people
on the left
uh and people in georgia as an example
will they
be convinced that people who are
conservative
of african americans others who are
conservative are
to be you're to be wary of them i mean
how do you think this is being uh
registered amongst uh other americans
this rhetoric from the democrats
well let me tell you donald trump had a
good playbook he said to the
african-american community what do you
have to lose
well on the other hand joe biden said to
the african-american community if you
vote republican
they're going to put you back in change
well who was really switching and
baiting when i think about
joe biden nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
i'm reminded of the wizard of oz
uh one has no brain other has no courage
and the other has no
what you know what i'm saying and so
when i also think about them they're not
being led by
um dorothy and toto they're being led by
what
the wicked witch of the south is who
stakes the abrams stacey abram's been
paid
and been hustled uh to keep blacks
think that they are depressed that they
are victims and when you look at it
let's let's look at what's really going
on who's funding this
the liberals george zorros and others
they want black people even think
that they can't even afford an id
although you need one for joe biden's
uh covet passport you need one to check
in the hotel
it's just crazy i'm here tonight i
mentioned with the evans family white
black everybody in here in cartersville
they don't care about that
but the left is afraid that black people
are thinking more independently now
and that they are saying wait a minute
the democratic party has led us off a
cliff well i was good it was going to
mention
wherever we look whether it's los
angeles or san francisco or detroit or
baltimore
great american cities new york right
atlanta
that that things have not gotten better
in the urban areas wherever the
democrats are in control
there is this status quo of misery it is
the
21st century everyone deserves better
this country will only get better
when the lives of people on the margins
and people of color those
people who are minorities get better and
the democrats have convinced
many people that there's only one place
to go i believe that with you sir and
people like donald trump who clearly is
not going away
that we will make sure that we know that
there's
alternatives and an important uh way to
move forward uh thank you vernon
for being here tonight i really
appreciate it very important time thank
you sir
please go to jonesforgeorgia.com there
we go jones for georgia.com thank you
sir now come